The answer's 2 times 3a minus 7b squared. This was an example of a perfect
square practice problem. Did you get the right answer? Congratulations if you
did. Let's see how we got that answer. Remember, whenever I factor any
polynomial, I want to look to see if there's a greatest common factor. When I
look at the variables, I can see there is not a variable portion of a greatest
common factor. But, I notice 18, 84 and 98 are all even numbers. Since they're
all even numbers, I know that there is a greatest common factor of two. So the
first thing I want to do is factor out the two. When I factor out the greatest
common factor of two. I'm left with 9a squared minus 42 ab plus 49b squared.
What I notice when I look at this problem is that the first term and the last
term are perfect squares. Let me write it that way. 9a squared can be written as
the quantity 3a squared. 49b squared can be written as the quantity 7b squared.
When I see a perfect square in the first term, and a perfect square in the
second term. I have to check to see if the middle term is 2 times the square
root of the first term times the square root of the last term. Let's check. 2
times 3a times 7b is equal to. 21 times 2 is 42 ab. So we know that this is a.
Perfect square. Since the first term is 3a squared and the last term is 7b
squared and the middle term is 2 times the square root of the first term times
the square root of the last term, I know what's a perfect square. Now knowing
that it's a perfect squire I have to remember the formula. The square root of
the first term is 3A. I nee a minus because the middle term is minus. And then
the square root of the last term which is 7B and we square it. Now a good thing
to do when you're doing these factoring problems is to check your asnwer. When
you check you answer, let's foil this out. 3 a minus 7 b squared is 3 a minus 7
b times 3 a minus 7 b. 3 a times 3 a is 9 a squared. 3 a times negative 7 b is
negative 21 a b. Negative 7 b times 3 a is negative 21 a b. And negative 7 b
times negative 7 b is Positive 49b squared. So I can combine the 2 middle terms.
I can also multiply it through by 2. When I finish multiplying through by the
gcf, I get 18a squared minus 84ab plus 98b squared. Which is what we started
with. So we know that we got the right answer.